my name is brent chesser i'm one half of
wd detailing and today we're going to be
cleaning an extremely dirty car that
used to belong to a hoarder who's now in
treatment
when we first got this car we actually
had to leave it outside of our shop for
over a week just to let it air out
because it was one of the worst smelling
vehicles that we've ever been brought
only because there was so much grime and
grease in both the carpets and the seats
and there was just a ton of garbage
everywhere
the first thing we did was use the ozone
machine the ozone machine removes air
pollutants and odors while also killing
bacteria and viruses inside the car
which makes it a lot safer for us to
work in there
after taking the seats out the first
thing that we do is take all the trash
out and completely vacuum the car that
way we can really see what we're working
with
so when you see a car in this condition
it doesn't always make too much sense to
save it but this car was brought to us
by a really really nice gentleman named
parker he reached out to us and told us
that he wanted to clean the car and give
it away to someone who really needed it
that really touched us so we were
instantly in
as we were vacuuming we found a pile of
dead bugs that were just sitting on the
carpet right next to the back seat
and
it was mixed in with some hair and just
some of the goodies when you're
detailing disaster cars
when people leave food or anything of
that sort that starts breaking down
that's when the maggots start appearing
in their cars they vacuum up pretty
easily as long as they don't splatter
all over the carpet but even then you
can just extract them
this garbage was so stuck on we
literally could not get it off with our
hands even a power washer isn't good
enough to get it off so we'll use a
flathead screwdriver occasionally it
helps get stuff off of the surface that
we otherwise wouldn't be able to
it actually wasn't sticky or oily it was
kind of like a rough feeling like velcro
it's almost like that rough feeling
that's how
how bad this carpet was
if we didn't pull the carpet out of this
car there was no possible way we were
going to get it completely clean
especially with all the stains on it you
would normally want to replace this
carpet but we were trying to keep the
budget as low as possible as per parker
that's what he wanted to do
so the original color of this car's
carpets floor mat seats was a gray and
when we got it they were almost black
the stains in the carpet came from i
don't even know honestly we were just
assuming that it's like grease and dirt
and everything mixed together
we have this carpet brush that will get
any hairs out of the carpet because this
carpet also had what seemed like dog
hair in it as well and we got all of
that out with a vacuum and our brush
we used a degreaser instead of an
extractor soap only because degreaser is
a bit stronger
and then we went ahead and drill brushed
it into start getting it to work into
the fibers of the carpet
we ended up having a power wash and
extract this carpet four times
after you spend
20 minutes on the same stain or half an
hour and keep working at it and
you can tell that it's not changing
color it's not coming out anymore and
there's really not that much more you
can do you know as a detailer it's kind
of time to just call it
i would say 85
of the stains and the dirt were out of
the carpet
and about 15
that was just complete damage was never
gonna come out
we hung it up inside of a closet where
there's a heater so we actually had to
let it dry for two days
so dying the carpet was actually a
last-minute decision that i ended up
making myself the first step is to spray
dye on the carpet we use a brush to
brush it into the carpet to make sure
it doesn't just sit because if it sits
then the carpet will become like hard
bristly texture and then you'll go back
and you'll spray over it again and then
you just let it sit and dry and that's
really it the only things you want to be
careful about are inhaling the fumes so
we wore our respirators and because
we're in a parking garage we have a
really big exhaust fan right next to us
and we had that running the entire time
and we don't do this on normal carpets
or
honestly ever but when we saw that some
of the stains weren't coming out we
wanted to make sure that this is going
to really change someone's life and
they're going to be happy when they
receive it
embedded in the seats are grease
and there was so much of it after we did
the entire extraction the first time we
let it dry overnight and we came back
the next day
and it was
completely covered in grease again so
everything that was farther in the seat
came to the surface so we had to clean
them a second time
so after we spray our extractor soap
we'll let the soap sit for about a
minute or two and then we'll go ahead
and use the drill brush to agitate the
soap into the fibers and then we'll
clean it out with the extractor
the extractor has a little nozzle that
sprays hot water into the fibers of the
seat and then it also has a vacuum head
so as it's spraying the water into it
it's sucking the water out at the same
time
that way it can clean it
we have a clear head on it so we can
actually see all of the soap all of the
dirt coming out of the seat and when
that water coming through is completely
clear that's how you know when the seat
is clean
so now we're cleaning the back seat of
the car which was also one of the
grossest parts of the car and the first
thing we did was use the tornado to
spray off any of the dirt and that is
simply just an air compressor tool that
shoots out air in a tornado formation
and that'll get a lot of the dirt out of
the deeper fibers of the seat
and then after that we'll go on to the
extracting process
the tornado is best for getting any kind
of micro particles out of the carpet or
out of the seats and then dust or dirt
or anything that's on like the topical
layer as well
so at this point we're taking apart the
center console so we can get it out of
the car and pressure wash all of the
disgusting grease and mold and
everything off of it
dirt definitely gets behind both the
radio or any of the knobs on the center
console because that's where your hands
are touching a lot so by disassembling
those things and cleaning behind them we
know that we're sanitizing and doing the
best job that we possibly can sometimes
the torador can't get things that are
super stuck on if they're gooey or
anything like that almost like a glue
substance to plastics the air is not
going to do a good enough job so you
have to scrape it off and power wash it
[Music]
we wanted to give it a good exterior
cleaning too
it did have a thick layer of dust on the
exterior the engine bay was dirty the
wheels had brake dust all over them
surprisingly enough dirt or dust
actually acts as a protectant to paint
so when a car is dusty or covered in a
layer of dirt it protects it from the
sun's uv rays
so the first thing that we do is we
spray our degreaser all over the paint
because it's paint safe
and that'll just start loosening up any
of the dirt on the outside
and then we'll use our power washer to
get the dirt off
[Music]
[Music]
so after we wash the car we go ahead and
we spray the entire thing down with a
ceramic sealant while it's still wet
and that just gives it a little bit of
protection and also a shine after
we wash it and then we'll go ahead and
spray it down again before drying it
after we were done with it he actually
needed to take it back to his home shop
and do some mechanical work on it to
make sure it's safe for the people
whoever owns it next we're really happy
with the result of this car but what
meant the most to us is how parker
reacted because this was something
special to him and the fact that we got
to be a part of it is why we did it in
the first place
we do all these details absolutely for
free so we took this on because we
wanted to make a change and we wanted to
help a family that needed it
[Music]
you